[Musik]
der hat zehn sie
überall auf der welt
und gleicht
rund um die uhr
filmen kameras
packende
extrem ruhig bleibt ruhig
furchterregende
naturphänomene was sollen wir tun guck
dir das an man ist wie gelähmt
es gibt kein entkommen
das ist reality tv sie glauben sie
kennen das wetter diese experten
erklären was wirklich passiert das
wasser fließt in den wirbel mit
den spektakulärsten wetter videos der
welt
unter freiem himmel zu arbeiten kann
sehr aufregend sein
aber wenn dabei ein unwetter ausbricht
kann es ganz schön riskant werden
november 2005 in der innenstadt von
denver bei strahlend blauem himmel
deutet nichts darauf hin was gleich zwei
fensterputzer widerfahren wird die an
einem 31 stöckigen gebäude beschäftigt
sind die beiden wollten nur ihren job
machen also fenster putzen aber alles
gerät aus den fugen plötzlich fäden
windböen mit geschwindigkeiten von über
60 kilometer pro stunde um den
wolkenkratzer und reißen eine der
befestigungen des aufzugs ab
weiter oben ist der wind viel stärker
als unten am boden wo die fußgänger
laufen
je weiter oben desto größer die
windgeschwindigkeit
der aufzug fährt unkontrolliert fast 50
meter weit aus und prallt dann gegen das
gebäude
der aufprall ist ziemlich hart denn die
fenster von wolkenkratzern sind auch
sehr viel stabileren glas als die in
einfamilienhäusern und die fensterputzer
werden immer wieder dagegen geschleudert
so ein aufzug ist ziemlich leicht wenn
der fenster zerschlägt kann man sich
vorstellen wie stark der wind war
die alarmierte feuerwehr sucht
fieberhaft nach einem weg um zu
verhindern dass sich der aufzug komplett
selbstständig macht und abstürzt
diese jungs waren sicher in panik die
rettungskräfte schätzen ab welche
fenster der aufzug als nächstes treffen
wird und positionieren sich dort
verblüffenderweise geht ihr plan auf
endlich gelingt es der feuerwehr den
aufzug am gebäude zu sichern und die
zwei verängstigten männer zu bergen das
ist ein wahnsinns job in solcher höhe
fenster zu putzen was für glückspilze
hoffentlich haben sie sich den rest des
tages frei genommen
zeit für ein schnelles quiz
wolkenkratzer sind so ausgelegt dass
ihnen die belastung durch starke winde
nichts anhaben kann sie können um
mehrere zentimeter vor und zurück
schwanken um den druck des windes
abzufangen und schäden am gebäude zu
verhindern
januar 2005 während eines heftigen
wintersturms hat los angeles mit äußerst
starken regenfällen und flut artigen
überschwemmungen zu kämpfen
nl sind überschwemmungen ein echtes
problem denn erst regnet es sehr lange
gar nicht und dann kommen innerhalb
kürzester zeit ganze sturzbäche runter
ein fahrer kommt von der fahrbahn ab und
stürzt in die reißenden fluten eines
entwässerungskanal
sie sollen sich bereithalten
leute was den richtigen moment ab
[Musik]
er schafft es zum glück aufs dach das
ist der sicherste ort der fluss ist so
aufgewühlt er fließt sicher mit 30 40
kilometer pro stunde
es gelingt den feuerwehrkräften dem mann
ein seil zu werfen um ihn von seinem
autodach und damit aus den reißenden
fluten zu bergen weiter so weiter aber
kurz bevor sie ihn zu fassen kriegen
ist im wasser
wer wird der rettungsweste
er dachte sicher das war es jetzt ich
werde sterben
es ist ein wettlauf gegen die zeit in
lebend aus dem wasser zu bergen
die fließgeschwindigkeit ist ziemlich
hoch sie haben nach seinem sturz also
nur sekunden um ihn auf der anderen
seite abzufangen bevor sie ihm womöglich
nicht mehr helfen können
ein anderes rettungsteam reagiert
blitzschnell und wirft ihm ein zweites
seil zu
sie machten sich die strömung zu nutze
hielten ihn fest und manövrierten ihn
sicher ans ufer
[Musik]
er hat unglaubliches glück am leben zu
sein
der pazifische ozean november 2013 der
super teil von high rast auf die
philippinen zu
ein taifun unterscheidet sich nicht von
einem hurrikan im atlantik und dem
östlichen pazifik spricht man von
hurricanes im nordwestlichen pazifik im
asiatischen raum heißen sie tayfun
tayfun entstehen über warmem wasser und
im fall von herrn war der pazifik
ungewöhnlich warm weshalb er so
unglaublich schnell war
der profi sturmjäger josh morgan ist in
der philippinischen küstenstadt tacke
band city um den taifun zu dokumentieren
er bezieht ein relativ hoch gelegenes
hotel aber es scheint als hätte er sich
dramatisch verschätzt so einen
tropischen wirbelsturm hatte ich noch
nie gesehen ich bin erfahren und habe
schon viele gesehen aber das war
gruselig
der augen wall von typhoon hahn kann
nicht mehr weit sein
der wind erreichte geschwindigkeiten von
bis zu 315 kilometer pro stunde das
entspricht einem hurrikan der kategorie
5 und martin zum stärksten taifun der je
auf land getroffen ist
die sichtweite liegt fast bei null
wir reden hier von windstärken wie bei
einem heftigen tornado nur in einem
größeren gebiet
der taifun ist so groß dass er zwei
drittel der philippinen bedeckt die sich
über 1800 kilometer erstrecken als sich
der wind richtung südosten dreht wird
die innenstadt von massiven sechs meter
hohen flutwellen verwüstet wie bei einem
tsunami durch drang das wasser die
gesamte innenstadt und riss menschen und
gebäude mit sich und plötzlich wird
morgen vom sturmjäger zum lebensretter
sie schienen in schwierigkeiten zu
stecken also lief ich rundherum zu
helfen
sie riskierten ihr leben um diese leute
zu retten
[Musik]
so schnell wir konnten trugen wir ältere
menschen kinder andere leute die treppe
hoch in den zweiten stock um sie aus dem
wasser zu holen
[Musik]
türen und fenster wurden weggeweht das
dach flog davon es war verrückt
nach zwei stunden ist das unwetter
endlich vorbei morgen hat dazu
beigetragen vielen menschen das leben zu
retten aber die zerstörung ist immens
schätzungen zufolge starben durch taifun
hat auf den philippinen etwa 10.000
menschen
[Musik]
das war ein heftiger schlag darum bin
ich wohl auch ein paar mal zurückgekehrt
es hilft mir die überlebenden dort
wieder zu treffen und zu sehen wie die
stadt wieder zum leben erwacht
[Musik]
kaum jemand dürfte seine brötchen mit
einer extremeren und furchterregenden
tätigkeit verdienen als professionelle
sturmjäger
heutzutage sind so viele sturmjäger
unterwegs dass ich schon die straßen
verstopfen
ich brauche eine bessere sicht
aber auch profis können in gefahr
geraten mai 2014 mcneil janssen nebraska
der sturmjäger george clooneys und sein
team folgen einem tornado der stärke 3
als der plötzlich unerfreulich nahe
kommt
der wind kann ganz plötzlich drehen und
schon ist man zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort aber zu spät schon löst
sich ein großes verbindungsteil einer ak
bewässerungsanlage
wenn in den wind in den wind
das zeigt die gefahren für sturmjäger
selbst für sehr erfahrene es kann immer
etwas schief gehen besonders wenn
mehrere wirbel auftreten
ich habe mir fast in die hose gemacht
kann ich verstehen zum glück ist nichts
passiert das wäre schlimm ausgegangen
hätte das ding die frontscheibe
durchschlagen als sich die lage beruhigt
hat ein gutachten coronels und sein team
den schaden fast wie neu
so erzeugen tornados
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 300.000
kilometer pro stunde
dieser riesige tornado wurde im all
beobachtet
tornados im all entstehen durch starke
magnetische felder auf der sonne dieser
spezielle wirbelsturm mindestens drei
stunden lang an
zurück auf der erde
eric rohmer mai 2013
sturmjäger wie bränden sullivan und brad
wright sind einem sturm system auf den
fersen das schon über ein dutzend
tornados hervorgebracht hat und
zwar klar dass die stürme heftig werden
würden
und genau so kommt es aus einem starken
gewitter geht ein riesiger tornado der
stärke 3 hervor
unerklärlicherweise vollzieht er einen
plötzlichen richtungswechsel und kommt
nun direkt auf die sturmjäger zu
fahren nach süden sonst gehen wir drauf
geschwindigkeit und richtung änderten
sich so abrupt dass viele leute davon
überrascht wurden
aber selbst als sullivan & ride die
fahrtrichtung ändern wird alles nur noch
schlimmer der tornado bildet mehrere
wirbel aus
ein großer multipacks
das heißt nicht sie weg weg von den
winden
da herrschen echt heftige winde
während sich sullivan & ride südwärts in
sicherheit bringen wollen zog der
tornado über die umliegenden felder
ich sehe nicht wo ich hinfahre
dieser tornado hat völlig neue maßstäbe
gesetzt
letztlich wurde er zum größten tornado
der bisherigen amerikanischen geschichte
über vier kilometer breit sowas hat es
noch nie gegeben
letztlich gelingt sullivan & ride den
tornado zu entkommen ohne auch nur einen
kratzer davon zu tragen
was für glückspilze wirklich unglaublich
zur gleichen zeit trägt der meteorologe
mike batt seinen eigenen kampf mit dem
tornado aus und der verläuft sehr viel
knapper wir müssen weiter sonst holt das
ding uns ein aber es ist zu spät der
wagen in dem bett ist mit seinem team
sitzt wird fast 200 meter weit über ein
feld geschleudert
wir flogen in die luft und stürzte dann
zu boden
das auto überschlug sich wieder und
wieder und alles um uns herum fiel
auseinander so was wünsche ich wirklich
niemandem
glücklicherweise überleben bettes und
sein team den vorfall lediglich der
fahrer erleidet mehrere knochenbrüche
und muss operiert werden drei andere
sturmjäger kommen tragischer weise ums
leben
es war das erste mal dass profis dabei
getötet wurden
jeder sturmjäger weiß dass der job
gefährlich ist vielleicht ist es das was
uns an zieht aber je mehr leute da
draußen unterwegs sind desto mehr sind
in gefahr
um sich bei ihren potenziell
lebensgefährlichen einsätzen zu schützen
nutzen die beiden sturmjäger sean casey
und brennt wie eine art tornado panzer
dass tornado intercept vehicle kurz diy
wie
dieses fahrzeug ist darauf ausgelegt
durch einen tornado zu fahren sowas
macht sonst niemand
wie das batmobil für sturmjäger
[Musik]
2013 wird das tier wie im ländlichen
kansas auf seine bisher härteste probe
gestellt als casey und ivey mit voller
absicht in einen gefährlichen tornado
hinein steuern
sie gehen ein hohes risiko ein man
sollte die natur nicht zu sehr
herausfordern ich habe druck auf den
ohren eine kamera im inneren zeichnet
auf wie der tornado das fahrzeug umhüllt
das war sicher einer der gruseligsten
moment in ihrer laufbahn als sturmjäger
alles wird schwarz und fegt wie das
verderben über einen hinweg
die trümmer innerhalb eines tornados
können tödlich sein ebenso die winde
die windgeschwindigkeit im inneren des
tornados erreicht fast 300 kilometer pro
stunde auf sehr viel mehr ist das thema
wie nicht ausgelegt
so ein tornado entspricht in etwa der
kategorie 4 die starken winde
beschädigen das dach des fahrzeugs
schwer und zerstören die filmausrüstung
aber casey und ivey bleiben unverletzt
sie waren bestimmt heilfroh als sich die
dunkelheit lichtete und sie es heil
überstanden hatten ich frage mich oft ob
es das wert ist aber sturmjäger haben
einfach dieses verlangen dass gestillt
werden muss
als meteorologe ist des marktes aufgabe
sich auf dem schlechtesten wetter zu
stellen
hier spürt man starken abwind im mai
2012 wird er im südwesten texas mit
einem gefährlichen gewitter system
konfrontiert einer sogenannten super
zelle wir sagen diese riesige sturmfront
auf uns zukommen vorneweg sieht man
immer die sogenannte burn walze diese
bedrohliche vorankündigung des unwetters
die aussieht als würde sie einen
verschlingen wollen
wenn sie vorüber zieht kann eine bühnen
front für starken wind sorgen
eine böden front entsteht wenn abwende
vom oberen teil des unwetters kalte luft
zum boden schicken daher rühren auch die
massiven bewegungen in alle richtungen
bühnen fronten können
windgeschwindigkeiten von über 160
kilometer pro stunde hervorbringen und
bettes ist mittendrin
böen fronten sehen schön aus schmecken
aber nicht man hat den mund voller dreck
und will sich nur noch die zähne putzen
er weiß dass da eine wand aus staub auf
ihn zukommt und zwar mit 50 60
kilometern pro stunde und trotzdem
bleibt er ungerührt dort um das alles
für uns einzufangen er schluckt sogar
da sage noch einer der wetterbericht sei
langweilig
sommer 2012 sieben jahre nach hurrikan
katrina trifft
hurricanes der hurrikan der kategorie
eins bringt heftige regenfälle und
starken wind mit sich
die niederschlagsmenge war enorm das war
ein ausgewachsener sturm
ist nach wie vor gefährlich und wird
sich nicht so bald auflösen
wettermoderator europa muss einen
geeigneten ort finden um die schwere des
unwetters zu vermitteln das ist live da
kann immer was schiefgehen aber in dem
moment denkt man nur an die sendung
[Musik]
als 16 windgeschwindigkeit auf 130
kilometer pro stunde anwächst läuft
broker ernsthaft gefahr den halt zu
verlieren
er wurde von wind und regen
durchgeschüttelt man musste sich dagegen
stemmen sonst war es vorbei bei seinem
kollegen jim carrey zeigt sich derweil
eine ganz andere lage wenn man in einer
der abgewandten nebenstraßen ist
schützen einen die gebäude kein torri
hat dort keinerlei probleme warte ich
komme bald canori bemerkt dass rocker in
schwierigkeiten steckt eilte ihm zu
hilfe
kam mitten in der live-schalte rüber um
mich zu stützen na bitte ich bin froh
dass er da war in so einer situation
will man gute leute um sich haben und es
gibt keinen besseren als schirm
glücklicherweise können sich beide
reporter auf den beinen halten und in
sicherheit bringen aber das nur langsam
weiter ziehende unwetter kostet im
verlauf von zwölf tagen 34 menschenleben
und verursachte schäden in höhe von rund
zehn milliarden dollar
juli 2012 konnten lake british colombia
dieses beliebte ausflugsziel wirkt
idyllisch aber der schein trügt
da steht eine frau und sie zu irgendwas
auf es ist klar dass etwas näher kommt
in der ferne brechen zweige man fragt
sich was da los ist
was steckt hinter dem mysteriösen
geräusch
wie aus dem nichts ergießt sich ein
massiver erdrutsch mit einer
geschwindigkeit von rund 140 kilometer
pro stunde über den berg an ein
kanadisches nachrichten team
dokumentiert das geschehen
es hätte uns voller riecht vor fünf
minuten starten wir noch da kurz zuvor
hatte das nachrichten die man über
gestanden was jetzt vom erdrutsch
verwüstet wird dort hielt sich auch ein
pärchen auf das sich in letzter sekunde
in sicherheit brachte
ohne boot in der nähe hätte man im
gebiet des erdrutsches keine chance noch
rechtzeitig wegzukommen
ein erdrutsch wird von zu viel wasser im
boden ausgelöst beispielsweise nach
starken regenfällen oder schneeschmelze
auch abholzung ist eine ursache bäume
gestein alles gerät ins rutschen und
kommt den berg runter angetrieben von
der schwerkraft und dem überschüssigen
wasser da herrschen unvorstellbare
kräfte
auf der mcmurdo forschungsstation in der
antarktis ist jeder arbeitstag ein
überlebenskampf hier wird das klima
nicht nur erforscht es ist auch hautnah
spürbar
diese umgebung ist lebensgefährlich
sieh dich
selbst drinnen sieht aus wie in einem
tiefkühlschrank wie muss es erst draußen
seien
die ice nicht an der tür lässt ja schon
erahnen was einen dahinter erwartet
wir machen jetzt die tür auf die tür zu
einer anderen welt
bereit
ein kleines bisschen windig da draußen
solange man noch kein wetter der klasse
eins in der antarktis erlebt hat weiß
man wohl nicht was kalt wirklich
bedeutet
das sind schon harte wetterbedingungen
die windstärke ist fast wie bei einem
hurrikan
bei windgeschwindigkeiten von über 100
kilometer pro stunde kann es
lebensgefährlich sein von einem gebäude
ins nächste zu gehen
man kann stundenlang keine 30 meter weit
sehen und die gefühlte lufttemperatur
liegt bei deutlich unter minus 70 grad
celsius
können sie sich so ein arbeitsumfeld
vorstellen
wenn man nur rund einen meter weit sehen
kann und sich dann draußen verläuft kann
das selbst in kompletter schutzkleidung
den tod bedeuten
innerhalb von minuten können
erfrierungen auftreten
mehr als 1000 menschen leben und
arbeiten auf der mcmurdo
forschungsstation während des winters
sind allerdings nur rund 200 vor ort es
gehört schon einiges dazu in so einer
umgebung zu arbeiten
wie gut kennen sie sich in der antarktis
aus
[Musik]
am 24 märz 2015 kletterte das
thermometer bis auf 17 einhalb grad
celsius die höchste temperatur die je in
der antarktis gemessen wurde
januar 2011 vor der südinsel neuseelands
zwei fischer kapitäne haben es eilig
ihre fangfrische ware an land und auf
den markt zu bringen
aber nach einem schweren sturm wurm
wassermassen aus dem grevener in die
stürmische gewässer der tasman see und
erzeugen große
unvorhersehbare wellen
das ist ein türkisches gebiet mit all
dem wasser aus dem fluss und der
wütenden seele
die boote kommen nicht weiter sie können
wieder zurück aufs offene meer noch
schaffen sie es an land jetzt geht es um
leben oder tod die riesigen wellen
könnten die boote problemlos zum kentern
bringen
die wellen kommen aus allen richtungen
und schütteln sie durch
sie können überhaupt nichts tun sie sind
dem mehr hilflos ausgeliefert es grenzt
an ein wunder dass sie nicht kollidieren
seitliche wellen sind gar nicht gut
sobald man ins rollen gerät und wasser
ins boot kommt beginnt man zu sinken
durch die starke strömung und die wellen
kommen die boote einfach nicht voran
die wellen kommen von links und rechts
und hinten und man muss jedes mal den
kurs ändern das kostet viel zeit und
energie
[Musik]
diese tückische stelle hat schon viele
menschenleben gekostet aber dieses mal
überstehen die boote den sturm
unbeschadet und erreichen den sicheren
hafen
[Musik]
zum glück sind die beiden nicht gekannt
hat
unglaublich dass die bootes an der
sandbank vorbei in den hafen geschafft
haben
juli 2013 in der nähe von mailand es ist
ein ganz normaler tag im büro bis einige
angestellte bemerken was sich vor ihrem
fenster abspielt
sie sehen nach draußen und sind völlig
erschrocken wer hätte keine angst wenn
er einen tornado vom fenster sieht ein
heftiges gewitter hat einen tornado der
stärke 2 entstehen lassen der grosse
trümmerteile durch die luft wirbelt
man kann im inneren des wirbels die
drehbewegung sehen und erkennen wie
heftig der tornado ist und wie schnell
er rotiert
in filmen wird es immer so dargestellt
als würde man vom tornado ein gesagt
tatsächlich sind es aber die
herumwirbelnden trümmerteile die
menschen töten schon ein solches
trümmerteil das mit 250 sachen durch die
luft schießt kann ein fenster zerbrechen
und dann tobt der tornado auch drinnen
[Applaus]
plötzlich wird allen klar gott es ist
ernst wir müssen uns in sicherheit
bringen sonst gibt es verletzte
die angestellten suchen schutz unter
ihren schreibtischen
das ding hat sogar bäume zerlegt es
könnte also einen baumstamm oder große
äste durchs gebäude schleudern das wäre
eher schlecht wenn man unter einem tisch
haut
glücklicherweise wird niemand verletzt
experten raten bei tornados dennoch zu
einem anderen vorgehen
gehen sie in die unterste etage des
gebäudes in einem innen liegenden raum
bringen sie so viele wände wie möglich
zwischen sich und den tornado
von heftigen winden zu rauer see im
nordatlantik vor der küste schottlands
setzt 1 23 meter langes fischerboot
einen notruf ab
im atlantik können die schiffe den
gewaltigsten wellen auf erden ausgesetzt
seien
eine riesige welle hat das boot zum
kentern gebracht als der
rettungshubschrauber der küstenwache
eintrifft klammern sich fünf fischer
verzweifelt am heck fest
was hat dann ins boot ein und brachte es
zum sinken ein boot in so einer lage das
ist das letzte was man sich wünscht da
ist einiges schief gegangen sie können
sich nur festhalten und hoffen dass
rechtzeitig hilfe kommt sie müssen
unglaubliche angst gehabt haben
unter einsatz seines lebens gelingt es
einem rettungshelfer einen der fische in
sicherheit zu bringen aber die anderen
haben weniger glück eine welle spült sie
vom gekenterten boot in die eiskalte see
jetzt ist wirklich eile geboten
das wasser ist kalt da kann es sehr
schnell zur unterkühlung kommen die
überlebenschancen sind äußerst schlecht
wenn man bei solchen bedingungen ins
wasser fällt
die wellen brechen direkt neben dir sie
können dich unter wasser drücken und du
trinkst noch dazu könnten die
trümmerteile im wasser treffen
gerade noch rechtzeitig gelingt es der
küstenwache zwei weitere männer zu
bergen während ein rettungsschiff den
rest der besatzung aufnimmt alle
schiffbrüchigen werden wegen
unterkühlung behandelt
wenn die mitarbeiter der küstenwache bei
so einem wetter raus fahren riskieren
sie dabei ihr leben dass sie dazu bereit
sind verdient schon anerkennung
keiner der fischer wurde verletzt
unglaublich alle haben es überstanden
der gefährliche job der rettungskräfte
wird von harten wetterbedingungen alles
andere als erleichtert und manchmal
droht die witterung sogar einen einsatz
zu torpedieren
juni 2002 im san bernardino national
forest und mehrere brände ausgebrochen
begünstigt durch trockenheit extreme
hitze um die berüchtigten santa ana
winde
da kamen im grunde die schlechtesten
voraussetzungen zusammen
die bühne können problemlos
geschwindigkeiten von 80 bis 100
kilometer pro stunde erreichen dadurch
schreitet das feuer rasant voran
die brände haben fast 3000 hektar land
zerstört und stellen eine direkte gefahr
für 500 häuser da hunderte
feuerwehrkräfte versuchen zu verhindern
dass das inferno den highway überwindet
was die situation so gefährlich macht
ist dass der wind sehr schnell die
richtung ändern kann
blitzschnell ist man vom feuer
eingeschlossen das kann ziemlich
beängstigend werden
[Musik]
sechs meter hohe flammen zwingen die
feuerwehrkräfte schließlich zum heiligen
abzug
man sieht die angst in ihren augen es
ist krass den profis anzumerken dass sie
sich fürchten und nur noch weg wollen
bei diesem einsatz war es wirklich knapp
für einige sogar zu knapp drei
einsatzkräfte erleiden verbrennungen
ersten und zweiten grades nach einem
mehr als zwei tage währenden kampf
gelingt es endlich den brand zu löschen
man kann die feuerwehr gar nicht genug
für die tapferkeit bewundern sich
solchen gefahren zu stellen um häuser
und menschen zu schützen das sind für
mich wahre helden
vom kampf gegen die flammen zum kampf
gegen die fluten im august 2011 tritt
oracle ihn als tropischer wirbelsturm
auf land er überzieht teile von new
jersey mit sintflutartigen regenfällen
diese führen zu heftigen
überschwemmungen im gesamten nordosten
weitläufige sturmfluten bringen
hochwasser mit sich das ganze städte
überschwemmt wenn flüsse über die ufer
treten fließt das wasser zum niedrigsten
punkt und wenn das die stadt ist in der
du wohnst wird dein haus einfach
überflutet man will hat es besonders
schlimm getroffen
dort wird die nationalgarde zur
unterstützung eingesetzt
in einem verzweifelten versuch hilflose
menschen zu bergen überqueren zwei
militärische amphibienfahrzeuge eine
überschwemmte kreuzung
[Musik]
diese trucks sind darauf ausgelegt
durchs wasser zu fahren der lufteinlass
ist sehr weit oben angebracht so dass
der motor trotzdem mit luft versorgt
werden kann
aber die fahrzeuge bleiben liegen und
sind völlig dem hochwasser ausgeliefert
sie gehen unter
stadtluft ist wasser eingedrungen jetzt
sitzen sie fest
entweder war der lufteinlass nicht hoch
genug angebracht oder sie sind in ein
schlagloch oder ähnliches geraten
letztlich kommt die feuerwehr von man
will die nationalgardisten zur hilfe
warnschilder an überfluteten straßen
sind also nicht nur für uns gedacht
sondern offenbar auch für rettungskräfte
man muss ihnen zugute halten dass sie
leben retten und sich dafür in gefahr
begeben
hurrikan irene kostete mehr als 40
menschen das leben und verursachte
schäden in höhe von sechseinhalb
milliarden dollar
wie gut kennen sie sich mit hurricanes
aus
[Musik]
normalerweise treten hurricanes einzeln
oder gelegentlich zu zweit auf aber im
august 2015 bildeten sich gleich drei
hurricanes im mittleren und östlichen
pazifik um alle drei waren hurrikan der
kategorie 4
schlechtes wetter kann einem gehörig den
tag versauen das müssen auch diese
beiden elektriker in oklahoma city
feststellen als sie im märz 2015 zur
arbeit fahren der wetterbericht warnt
vor schweren gewittern aber ihnen steht
noch viel schlimmeres bevor
oh verdammt ist direkt vor uns genau das
ist ein großer tornado der stärke 2 mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 190
kilometer pro stunde sieht aus als
würden sie direkt auf den tornado zu
steuern
da kann man nur noch hoffen und beten
mann sitzt in der falle
der band wird ganz schön
durchgeschüttelt
alter da blitzt es da ist der kopf die
sind echt nah dran
aber auch nachdem der tornado
vorbeigezogen ist droht noch immer
gefahr sie werden vom sogenannten out
flow getroffen der ebenfalls gefährlich
ist rückseitige abwende rolf lay down
treffs oder kurz a&f dies können dazu
beitragen dass weitere tornados
entstehen
darf die winde sind äußerst gefährlich
sie erstrecken sich viel weiter als der
tornado selbst die abwende sind so
heftig dass sie einen vorbeifahrenden
lkw umreißen
unglaublicherweise bleiben die
elektriker und der fahrer des lkw
unverletzt
helfen das ganze ding ist einfach
umgekippt und liegt auf der seite
sie hatten großes glück dass die
geschichte so glimpflich verlaufen ist
bei schlechtem wetter ist die arbeit im
freien kein vergnügen bei manchen
stürmen fragt man sich ob man da noch
herauskommt wenn dann noch das
unvorhersehbare verhalten von tieren
hinzukommt kann der job wirklich riskant
werden
januar 2010 in upstate new york 30
kilometer vor der kanadischen grenze
sind einsatzkräfte alarmiert worden um
einen hund zu bergen
der arme hund wird mir so leid gut
festhalten konnte man denkt sich passt
schon hunde haben ihr fell und können
schwimmen aber die wassertemperatur
liegt bei 0 grad legte sich auf den
bauch
spätestens nach 15 bis 30 minuten kann
es zu schweren erfrierungen oder sogar
zum tod kommen
zum schutz vor den eisigen temperaturen
im fluss trägt einer der männer einen
speziellen wasserfesten überlebensanzug
[Musik]
als er sich dem hund nie hat es fängt er
plötzlich an zu jaulen als wollte er
sagen bitte rette mich
papin halten fest
aber noch ist der vierbeiner nicht außer
lebensgefahr
sie müssen ihn übers eis 10 er kann sich
nicht bewegt
[Musik]
oder kühlung gibt es auch bei hunden es
fühlt sich an die tausend nadelstiche am
ganzen körper äußerst schmerzhaft
das tier wird sofort in wärmende decken
eingewickelt
die rettungshelfer sind einfach gute
menschen die alles in bewegung setzen um
den kleinen kerl aus dem eisigen wasser
zu holen
erfreulicherweise hat er verunglückte
den schrecken gut überstanden und es
geht ihm prächtig
wie kommt es eigentlich dass tiere im
ewigen eis nicht erfrieren
eisbären zb scheinen die arktische kälte
gut zu überstehen indem sie vermehrt
stickstoffmonoxid produzieren eine
chemische verbindung mit deren hilfe die
zellen nährstoffe in energie umwandeln
von eisiger kälte zu einem eisigen
gewitter das sich im juni 2015 über
montaner zusammenbraute die sturmjäger
mit herold und brannten lorenz
beobachten vor ort wie sich die super
zelle formt es hagelt der hagel bedeckt
die straße und fällt immer weiter
diese aufnahmen zeigen sehr schön dass
ein gewitter auch ohne tornados heftig
und zerstörerisch sein kann
die größten hagelkörner haben einen
durchmesser von fast sechseinhalb
zentimetern und schlagen rissen die
frontscheibe des fahrzeugs
golfballgroße hagelkörner hinterlassen
dellen am auto wie baseball große
hagelkörner können frontscheiben
zertrümmern stellen sie sich vor was sie
mit ihrem kopf machen der wind weht mit
100 110 sachen
was ist das da auf der straße wo gott da
steht will
siehst du oh nein sich ganz schön
mitgenommen aus ein gabel bob junges ist
im niederprasselnden hagel schutzlos
ausgeliefert und sucht verzweifelt
deckung
wildunfall tiere werden draußen oft von
hagelschauern überrascht und können
dabei sogar ums leben kommen genau wie
menschen die von baseball großen
hagelkörnern getroffen werden
wir müssen ihm helfen nur wie
es ins auto bringen aber das ding können
wir es irgendwie abschirmen mit einer
jacke
einer der männer beschließt dem jungtier
zu hilfe zu kommen trotz der gefahren
schaut euch den typ an das ist doch wohl
echt süß
dieses hilflose kleine fellbündel geht
einem wirklich zu herzen
ich ziehe meinen hut vor dieser
rettungsaktion als der hagelschauer
nachlässt entlassen sie das jungtier
wieder in die wildnis
glaubst du ihm geht's gut denkt schon
800 kilometer weiter westlich in einer
abgelegenen gegend in idaho kämpfen will
tierpfleger ein hilfssheriff und ein
anwohner und das leben eine elchkuh
eine große schwere elch kunst aufs eis
gelaufen und eingebrochen
die wassertemperatur liegt knapp über
null es ist noch nicht gefroren aber
nicht viel mehr als ein grad war das
entzieht dem tier die körper waren
wahnsinn dass es sich so ausdauernd zur
wehr setzt
die helfer wissen es muss schnell gehen
sie beschließen dem tier einen weg auf
festen boden zu ebnen
ihr vorgehen war echt clever sie haben
das eis ausgelegt so dass die elchkuh
wieder festen halt und boden unter den
hufen bekam
aber jetzt sind sie selbst in höchster
gefahr sie könnten direkt neben dem elch
ins wasser stürzen das wäre extrem
ungünstig komm schon kaum schon los
steh auf mag schon
eine super truppe sie schaffen es mit
geduld und genial i tät dieses lebewesen
letztlich ans rettende ufer zu bringen
für so etwas lohnt es sich doch den
elementen zu trotzen
unglaublich dass der mensch in der lage
ist eine so faszinierende kreatur zu
retten denn das sind elche eindeutig